we've talked about this we're going to
talk more about it for about a year and
a half
you're down to two lanes in each
direction on the 95
515 between the spaghetti bowl and all
the way over to eastern as
the nevada department of transportation
has a huge project going on there now a
live look with our traffic camera shows
boom there it is so the northbound side
is still moving right along
these are the folks who are trying to
get onto the south 95 from the north 15.
that's going to take a while these are
the folks on the 95 itself and that is
already backing up
outside the spaghetti bowl we do have
some detours for you can skip the whole
thing
by using las vegas boulevard or eastern
for north south travel
and you go up to washington or bonanza
or down to charleston and just skip the
whole thing
let's get right down there to that
traffic squeeze hector mejia near
downtown
with a closer look boy oh boy what fun
hector
oh yeah hey there nate good morning
we've already heard some honking here
throughout the morning and right next to
us we're safely standing next to the
casino center off ramp
from southbound 95 which is closed until
september first
and way out there in the distance you
can see that traffic moving along okay
right now that is the southbound lane
the southbound side of u.s 95 where work
began
on sunday and now starting tonight the
northbound side will be reduced down to
two lanes
the closures will be in effect as you
just mentioned until december 2022
closures between the i-15 all the way
down to eastern
for the 40 million project that's fixing
the elevated freeway
parts of which are nearly 60 years old
as we mentioned work in the southbound
lane started sunday night and tonight is
when a bigger traffic impact will begin
starting at 9 p.m on the northbound side
and plans call for repairing repaving of
the surface as well as adding a new
southbound auxiliary lane
re-striping when they're done and also
making the eastern off ramp
wider for traffic work will take place
in phases but will not be complete
until a long time from now around
christmas of next year 2022
ndot says work will happen six days a
week
and the agency built incentives in the
contract to get everything
wrapped up on time but still we'll
certainly see the traffic impact for
months ahead for the next year and a
half or so so also
ndot created a website to help drivers
navigate their way through that traffic
mess that website is called
i515project.com we'll go a little bit
more about that still ahead
in the next half hour reporting live in
downtown hector mejia
8 news now